hey Conan here and I'm standing with
nari nari
you are a State Farm agent yes what kind
of stuff do you insure everything a big
part of your job is empathy
being empathetic to people who are in a
stressful situation is that true
definitely okay do you mind if we
roleplay right now a little bit but say
I'm your your customer I'm Conan uh-huh
okay
ring-ring ring-ring ring-ring thank you
for calling Narcy farm office how may we
help you
all right my house I try to do the
washing myself a lot of soap right now
or do you need us to get you a place to
stay okay I can give you a check right
now from my office to get you a place to
stay over here is a car but it's gone
too it washed away so it's three hours
later ring ring ring ring ring ring
thank you for going 90 from I bought a
bunch of camels I bought a bunch of
camels in there fighting smashing every
here are things Department on the line
and let's walk through this together
right now the phone is too far away from
your face keep it up here yeah
definitely then we call 9-1-1 for you
I have an automobile that is very
priceless and it means a lot to me and
if you're okay
I'd like it show it to you and see if
State Farm might insure this automobile
sure behold Murray this is a Ford Taurus
this has been owned and driven by Conan
O'Brien yes yes but it's as you can see
it's a gorgeous car it's in great shape
it's in the original emerald green
they're the original tires a lot of
people say change the tires when they go
bald
I say no keep the original tires so it
slides around the road a lot this got
scraped up this was not my fault I was
trying to get through a tollbooth
without pain and I accelerated and they
tried to lower the gate hey I have a fun
fact about this car this car and this is
absolutely true was once driven by Brad
Pitt
yes Brad Pitt did a segment where he
drove my Ford Taurus you can take a look
at that clip right now owned by Conor
Bryan celebrity of this stature
partially destroyed by Brad Pitt
celebrity of this stature and this is
gonna make the car worth more a little
scratch that this one is an interesting
celebrity story Sean Hayes you know from
Will & Grace yeah he was on his bicycle
and I wasn't paying attention and I hit
him and he went right into a sycamore
tree I took off okay here we go this is
what phones look like in the early 90s
well I'm going to show you on a 1990s
phone what a 1990s
phone conversation looked like hello
that's right I'm in my car and I'm
talking to you hey did you get those
tickets to see the spin doctors
yeah after we watch Mad About You we can
go see the spin doctors I know I'm
excited about President Bill Clinton -
yeah he'll he seems like a guy who would
never do anything weird by those were
regular conversations that I had I don't
think he can put a price on this car if
you were to try to put a price on his
car you'd be in the tens of millions of
dollars is my guess
especially with Brad Pitt in the car I
mean not that is your car is not it's I
mean it's valuable because it's yours
you just screwed up big-time you just
screwed up oh so suddenly Brad Pitt is
more attractive than I am I don't see it
frankly I think he looks weird his face
is all mushed up
I'm objectively more attractive than
Brad Pitt I mean everybody has it if I
can't agree or disagree with you right
now the car is a lot of sentimental
value okay and not only because Brad
puts that in it's not bringing up Brad
Pitt you and I were doing great and then
suddenly it's Brad Pitt this bread did
that I'm just gonna be his fake firm rep
why am I even here
does it enhance the value of the car at
all if I were to pose on it like this
you know tough assessment for me to me
naari how long are you willing to swatch
me do this my question well I do have to
get back to the office
oh yeah suddenly the office calls does
it our studio check out my car
you